i've got to say up front this wasn't my
favorite episode of for all mankind
i guess it's inevitable in a story with
so many things going on but i didn't
find myself interested in a lot of what
unfolded here
that said it did have some great moments
a latest celebration at jsc
gordo's son finding him in the closet
with his helmet on
and then karen ruthlessly spoiling the
wrathicon for
ed those are all things i'm gonna
remember hey guys pete here
this is my for all mankind season 2
episode 5 breakdown
the episode was titled the weight
w-e-i-g-h-t
although it did feel a little bit more
like the weight w-a-i-t
to me just a quick spoiler warning if
you haven't watched the episode yet this
video will
absolutely spoil it and with that out of
the way let's get right to it
the opening of this episode was
absolutely amazing though
tracy's on the moon we see this glorious
sequence where she comes down the stairs
looks around at the surface is
completely odd
and then we learned that her cameraman
forgot to hit record
so she has to do it all again it's
definitely one of the high points of the
episode
and the fact that she has to go back and
redo it to recapture that feeling of
inspiration
does work well for where her time on the
moon goes
i wish it just could have been a little
bit more fun to watch we see
a lot of moon time in this episode and
we also see that she is the rock star of
the bunch
this sets her apart from the other
people there kind of isolates her
but at the same time she's on tv she's
talking to johnny carson
which all works to make it kind of hard
to feel bad for
a couple of things that stand out here
though the old linus
the other new guy that was there just
before her tells her how he remembers
watching her save molly's life on tv
and how he's always looked up to her for
it and that serves as a good reminder
because
tracy's struggle in the first season was
that no one thought she was up to the
task
now in this episode we see that that
struggle has shifted
in the direction of she's kinda getting
everything that she wanted but it
doesn't appear to be making her happy
and that comes out explicitly when she
goes to visit deke's grave at the end
so we see her struggle with that we see
that she can't sleep she starts drinking
she blocks the air vent in her bunk that
leads to an alarm going off
and pissing everybody off including her
commander
and overall in her first month things
are not going well
and she's got five more to go so we're
gonna see things change for her going
forward
no more tv interviews no more special
treatment
the other thing we see is that she can
fly the lsam
she's still a good pilot so we'll see
where they take things from here
in baldwin land karen gets the call that
ed's plane went down
we see her with kelly she's waiting to
find out what happened
she's a nervous wreck understandably and
eventually they get the call that he's
alright
and she makes a point of telling kelly
this is what it's like for the people
you love
and you should know that when ed comes
home in the morning
we see that he's beat up from the
ejection but the doctor said he'll be
all right
karen puts up a facade pretending like
she doesn't care
everything is fine and she's just going
to go to work at 6 00 a.m
because everything's fine and of course
ed and kelly can see through this but
that's the way she's dealing with things
there's really no progress in this later
we see at the outpost danny kelly and
karen are all eating together
and when ed shows up everything is still
pretty awkward
danny leaves kelly goes back to work and
karen still doesn't really want to hang
out with that at all
as i mentioned in the beginning she
makes sure to spoil rather khan for him
when he asks her to go
because she's already seen it with kelly
at the end of the episode we see karen
and danny have a conversation at the
outpost
he tells her memories about coming over
to the house when he was a kid
brings up the fact that he saw her
dancing by herself to elvis in the
living room when she didn't know he was
there
and then they talk about shane something
that they both have that ties them
together
they both still really miss shane after
they talk we see karen go home put on an
elvis record and dance by herself in the
living room
as far as consequences for what ed and
gordo did
there are none really watching margot
molly and payne
listening to their tape of them doing
the dogfight was hilarious though
but yeah i mean big surprise molly takes
their side
she's pretty firm about it backing up
the other astronauts and
not sure if that's going to lead to
something else down the road
the only other thing with molly in this
episode is we see her talking to the
astronauts who are taking the guns up to
the moon
it's an important development we've been
waiting for this to happen
but it's kind of just sandwiched in
there and the main thing in relation to
molly
is that we see that our eyesight is
failing and that could be
related to what happened to or being
exposed to radiation on the moon
for what it's worth we do see the guns
arrive so they are there
at jamestown base but we have to wait
until later to see what the reaction is
down the road
gordo does seem to be taking things
seriously at this point
we see that he's still struggling inside
the helmet but he's trying to do what he
can
at home to get over the fear we got a
little bit of a montage of him like a
training montage where he's getting
himself back into shape
throwing his liquor bottles away so it's
hinting that he's on the road to
redemption
we also see elena show up for her first
day of work at nasa
i mentioned i really liked how she did
the whole screaming behind the
soundproof glass thing it felt like a
triumph
we see that she's excited this is a
dream that's realized
and is confirmed that she is working on
the apollo soyuz
project which is the one where danielle
is going to be meeting with the russians
for the handshake in space
and we see her have this awkward
exchange where she's being asked
questions about her background and she
really doesn't want to talk about it
it makes you think there are multiple
reasons why she wouldn't want to get
into her background
and it's kind of interesting to see
where that goes
when i was first watching it i was
thinking like maybe she
is socially awkward like extremely
socially awkward in these kind of things
but it really makes more sense that
since her father was deported
that she has a strained relationship
with margot
who also did her a big favor putting her
in this position
that she might just really not want to
explain how she got there
it seems like they're setting her up to
do something
in relation to this project figure
something out make a name for herself
it's certainly the trajectory you would
expect her story to take
so i'm hoping that we'll get to learn a
little bit more about where she's been
at for the last nine years
what's really going on with her getting
fired from all these places
because that doesn't just happen for no
reason right
and then i guess the last big story of
this episode
was ellen and pam reuniting she goes to
see her at a poetry reading
pam is living with a partner she's in
austin so she's out
she's not closeted like she was when she
was with ellen
she seems happy she tries to play it off
that she's excited to see ellen
and there's a couple fake outs here
where you think that they're not gonna
hook back up but at the end of the day
they do
and it is good to see that pam's back
that would have been a loss if she just
disappeared from the story but again
this kind of just felt like it was
sandwiched in there among all the other
things happening
seeing them back together would
certainly make you think that she's
going to end up making their
relationship
public of course she could go the sally
ride route
and never explain it until after she
dies
but you can't really see pam coming back
into her life unless that happens
there's really only two options here
ellen quits nasa and she goes to austin
and they live together there
or ellen comes out and pam and her get
together publicly
and they deal with the fallout and
that's pretty much everything that
happened
that's the big stuff so yeah my least
favorite episode of the season so far
still not my least favorite episode of
tv i've watched recently
and there were some of my favorite
little moments thrown in there
i guess a lot of it has to do with me
not feeling that interested in tracy's
story right now
and it's not because she's a bad
character really it's just that there's
so many other things going on
and this was one of my big problems with
the first season of this show
you have all these interesting things
going on side by side but they don't
always
work well together it's interesting when
you step back and think about it tracy
is kind of the rock star right
if ed had gone back if gordo hadn't lost
his mind
molly isn't inclined to go looking for
that kind of attention
any one of them could have been the rock
star because the space program is
popular in that timeline
but when you think about it like that
then yeah of course tracy is a good
candidate for that but it's not
something endearing necessarily
and then like i said it's kind of hard
to feel bad for her because
she's got a pretty good life it's all
probably leading to something
i think in the case of what's going on
with tracy right now
and what's going on with karen right now
i just don't find myself wondering how
they're going to get through it or what
is the kind of ending or the kind of
thing i want to see happen to them
right now in this part of the story with
ellen it's more cut and dry you know you
want to see your get together with pam
if that's what they're going to do you'd
like to see her be able to be who she is
have a fulfilling life she certainly
earned that
she's certainly good at her job and all
that so it's a little more cut and dry
in that situation
i am curious to see what's going to
happen with elena it's a pretty nice
touch that she's been
around jsc enough as a child through a
relationship with her father and with
margo
that she knows enough when she goes into
the observation room that no one can
hear her and she just goes ahead and
cuts
loose but as she was in that
conversation i did think about the fact
that she's been fired
everywhere else that she's worked and
it's clear that working at nasa
is important to her this is her lifelong
dream right so
definitely some potential there and i
think that's a good place to leave it
we'll see where things go next week let
me know in the comments what you think
what you're hoping to see next and you
know we're halfway there now so
things should be picking up as we go
into the back half please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon